welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the batman trailer shows robert
pattinson
so stumped by ridler's riddles that he's
taken it out on his street fights
vengeance for the stupid my trailer
breakdown went into a pretty insane
level of detail with the many visual
clues in the riddler's first riddle
which some of us were able to solve
already but after reviewing it again
this trailer is
a super mysterious enigma with even more
clues to discuss
and no i'm not talking about that
quarterback's mask in the stairwell it
ain't a mask it's a flash of the gunshot
over exposing a normal face sorry to
break your hearts but don't worry the
owls are still very much behind
everything because i think
i cracked the riddler's second clue i'm
gonna break down all the new stuff i
found and spoiler warning because at
this rate i think i'm
predicting page 96 of the script okay by
now we know the answer to the riddler's
first riddle what does a liar do when
he's dead
and i explained how by using a simple
substitution cipher and how
only certain consonants tend to end
words repeated like that
you get the hilarious answer of he lies
still but the important element of that
answer is not the word play
it's the fact that it foretells the
riddler's next target now this victim
here is newly reelected got the mayor
don mitchell jr he lies
still is a clue hinting that the next
move will come where this victim's body
lies
his funeral lies still as a corpse in a
casket
and lies still as the reputation and
legacy of a dishonest politician
is immortalized in his eulogy in epitaph
but at this funeral crashes in
our next clue an suv covered in riddler
brand duct tape with the letters d-o-a
question mark driven by a hostage with
another strip of duct tape with no more
lies over his mouth a smartphone
apparently in speaker mode taped to his
hand
a yellow clue envelope taped to his
chest and worst of all for him
a bomb strapped to his neck and this
isn't any hostage
if you look closely i'm almost certain
this is actor peter sarsgaard who has
been credited in casting reports as
district attorney gil coulson dog gill's
got himself turned into a human bomb
again
oh and blood stains on the shirt oh jeez
this was a rental
so first the mayor of the city now the
district attorney
yeah this riddler is targeting
high-ranking gotham city leaders and
while we never get to see what is
in that yellow envelope in the trailer
we do hear what i think is at least part
of its contents
the voice of paul dano booms out over
the rest of the trailer
if you are justice please
do not lie what is the price
for your blind
and eye kind of sounds like it's being
electronically filtered through a
speakerphone
so this might be the riddler reading the
riddle back to batman
and yeah if you're a justice please do
not lie what is the price for your blind
eye
rhymes that statement is a riddle a
riddle that i believe is at least part
of riddle number two
so let's dive into it there are a lot of
ways you can interpret the words here
like what is the price for your blind
eye could be the riddler suggesting
batman and the police have
hypocritically
turned a blind eye to the corruption
within the city's leadership which the
riddler is now trying to expose
and the final exchange of the trailer
sheds more light on that
you're part of this too oh my part of it
you'll see now i'll notice that we don't
see pattinson's mouth move in the bat
cave there
but it sounds like their voices are
still echoing in a cavernous space
suggesting that they could be chatting
over the phone in the cathedral there at
the mayor's funeral
it's all one conversation and director
matt reeves suggested the mystery is
going to expose the wayne family's own
role
in the city's history of corruption so
you start to see that as it starts to
describe
this epic history of corruption in
gotham that you start to understand well
where did my family sit in that the term
blind eye could be read as a taut to
batman being blind as a bat
which was the final riddle answer of the
last time we saw a live-action film
riddler
you're as blind as a bat
exactly but blind as a bat is actually a
falsity
bats are not blind they see about as
well as humans do they just nocturnally
use echolocation to track their prey
not because they can only see at night
and not during the day but still it
could be used as a taunt
towards batman for being so focused on
nighttime criminal activity
that he overlooks the city corruption
being committed in broad daylight
still there is another interpretation i
think is
more telling i know i know these clues
are a bit hard to find and even harder
to decipher since we're not in the room
with them
we're looking at them through whatever
device they're using to watch this video
and a device you're probably more
accustomed to using for like oh say
fortnite speaking of which season 4 of
nexus war just released in fortnite
now is the perfect time to jump in if
you haven't downloaded fortnite already
use my tracking link in the description
below to download fortnites for
free and thanks to epic games for
sponsoring this video fortnite is the
world's most popular battle royale game
and is free to download and available on
pc
ps4 xbox nintendo switch and mobile
devices
in the new season those who purchase
fortnite's seasonal battle pass will be
able to unlock the likes of iron man
storm wolverine doctor doom groot
she-hulk
along with an amnesiac thor as they team
up to fight galactus devourer of worlds
i'm loving that brown and yellow
wolverine costume
galactus looks super cool in this not
only have the marvel heroes and villains
landed on the island but so have their
iconic locations
drop into the island and visit new and
upcoming locations like doom's domain
sentinel graveyard and more take up
super powers like dr doom's arcane
gauntlets groot's bramble shield
silver surfers board and more arriving
later in the season
download fortnite for free using my
dragon link in the description below
okay really i think the subject of the
second riddle is
lady justice who is often shown
blindfolded to symbolize impartiality
justice is blind lady justice in her
hands carries a scale and in the other
hand a sword
lady justice is an icon of a courtroom
setting and that first riddler clue
was a card depicting an owl with a
skeleton
behind it these two clues taken together
could be even stronger evidence that the
court of owls are behind all of this the
court of owls is the secret cabal of
leaders running gotham for centuries
and now the riddler could be exposing
the skeletons in the closets
of the owls by killing off the city
leaders that they corruptly put in power
looking back at that first riddle it's
also interesting how its cover contained
a
word with an extra o to make a double
entendre
like an owl hoot and the second riddle
does the same thing
the car of the district attorney is
marked d-o-a
it inserts an extra o in the middle of
the letters d
and a making the d.a the district
attorney
doa dead on arrival so what is the exact
answer for riddle number two what is the
price the riddler is asking about is it
corruption
is it the court of owls i think those
answers are too general the real answer
is likely to be another dark pun or a
turn of phrase that tells us something
about the riddler's next target
lady justice is blinded yet carries a
sword that sword symbolizes the swift
blow of justice
the executioner sword and the common
critique of justice being blind is that
it could be blind to the truth that
innocent people have historically lost
their heads in the name of justice so
while we don't know yet what exactly is
written inside that envelope going off
the sentence structure of riddle number
one
i'm willing to bet that the inscription
is something like what does
justice get when she's blind the answer
she gets
ahead and that head being the next
target the riddler believes is a just
execution
a particularly savage murder police
commissioner peter savage
beheaded setting up captain jim gordon
to take his place
look we know this riddler is a vicious
one he clearly has knowledge of
explosives
and we just learned that his mask is
modeled on the us military extreme cold
weather mask which along with its coat
are things that you can get from an army
surplus store
meaning edward nashton is a practical
killer who ain't afraid to get bloody
this could also explain another new
detail we spotted from the trailer the
moment
batman scuffles with the other gcpd cops
in the police station
during that scuffle if you look closely
there is a stretcher on the table
and batman's arms appear to be cuffed
behind his back
i think we may be looking at the
aftermath of that funeral bombing
which caught batman in the blast but
afterward the police commissioner was
found beheaded
and the cops already distrusting
batman's involvement in the string of
murders
now looking for someone to blame for
their death of their commissioner
cuff batman while he is incapacitated
and so like great batman detective
comics like the long halloween hush
gotham by gaslight batman is gonna have
to apply
actual detective work to sleuth out the
truth in order to prove his own
innocence
something that might be pretty hard for
bruce to do since i think we are also
likely to learn about his parents
involvement with the court of owls
in fact on this sunday's coming episode
of the big question we will be exploring
those detective cases
to evaluate how great of a detective
batman actually is and whether he's
worthy of the title the world's greatest
detective keep an eye out for it
not a blind one to join us as we try to
break this nerdy mystery in our downtime
join new rockstar's official discord
server which you can access by becoming
a patron at any tier
at patreon.comrockstars follow me on
instagram at eavos follow new rockstars
subscribe and hit that notification bell
for the latest deep dives into
everything you care about thanks for
watching batman
[Music]
you